the people of the world who've had
experienced Eastern Europeans who had to
live under the uh the dark umbrella of
Communism those who have escaped
tyrannical regimes that lady you head on
from South Korea when they come over
here now and they see what we're doing
with our freedoms which is essentially
turning them upside down and mocking
them and under under the name of
political correctness or wokism
insisting
pushing propagandizing evangelizing
these toxically stupid ideas and and
perverting the education system in their
Putin and the Warriors of the world as
Edward calls them They're laughing their
heads off
because they know this is a form of
almost Collective dementia
[Music]
hello everyone I'm here today with Mr
Rex Murphy which is always a pleasure
Rex is a Canadian commentator and author
primarily on Canadian political and
social matters he was the regular host
of CBC Radio 1's cross country checkup a
nationwide call-in show for 21 years
before stepping down in September of
2015.
he is perhaps Canada's best recognized
and most admired and indeed most loved
journalist pleasure to see you Rex I'm
glad we have a chance to talk again
I think we should go over that bio part
where you mentioned most loved I think
there are three dogs and two cats yeah
well it's hard to it's hard to believe
if you're loved but but it's definitely
the case so I wanted to talk to you
today about the Trudeau government and
just exactly what's going on I thought I
might give you a bit of background about
exactly why I thought we should talk
again so I've been traveling through the
U.S and Europe for the last three months
I think 40 cities in the U.S and then 14
cities in Europe and I've noticed I've
talked with a lot of people about
their attitude towards Canada and how
that's changed as a consequence of
Trudeau and so in the U.S what I noticed
in particular was that people whether
they were Democrats or
Republicans
were very unhappy with Trudeau's
treatment of the trucker Convoy and also
shocked I would say that he blamed it on
the Americans especially on the
conservatives and also appalled that he
froze bank accounts that was not a wise
move and then in Europe I would say
Canada's International reputation has
taken a vicious hit uh
people are shocked I would say again at
what happened around the trucker Convoy
specifically the freezing of the bank
accounts but also there's a fair bit of
Buzz about the new bill c-11 and the
internet censorship and so I don't think
Canadians really are aware of how
vicious a hit
the reputation of our country has taken
under our current prime minister and so
I thought I would talk to you about the
peculiar times that we seem to find
ourselves in in Canada my sense is that
we get a scandal every week and have for
about six months that under normal
circumstances would be sufficient to
bring down a government yeah
well I'll pick you up on a couple of
things before I go to the actual Scandal
Point uh in reference to Canada standing
either in the U.S or in Europe
even within the last three days uh with
the decision role versus Wade Mr Trudeau
was in Rwanda which is not near Quebec
when he commented on the operations of
the Supreme Judiciary of the United
States and probably the most electric
issue in American politics and here's
what he had to say I actually brought
the brought the paper with me I'm only
quoting a small bit of it Harry is
commenting on it this is very important
he's commenting on the Supreme Court one
third of the constitutional government
of the United States an equal party to
Congress and the executive this is the
prime minister in a separate country and
here's his first response to the
decision
the news coming out of the United States
is horrific
I pause there
he's not never mind the particular issue
he's saying that the operation judgment
determination and rumination of a court
of a Judiciary of the judicature of the
United States the Constitutional balance
part he's commenting on the operation of
the essential element of government and
especially on the judges and he's
calling it horrific number two he goes
on now he's going to what he would call
substance my heart goes out
to the millions of American women who
are now set to lose their legal right to
an abortion
the last phrase is patently false
but the biggest thing there is
who was he to play the middle Clinton
empathizer
to the constituents of another Nation
now if you were telling me he he's
earned a bad reputation in the United
States because
of of blaming American right-wing
authorities for for
bringing money into the Convoy which was
proven false the majority and by far of
the money that went in the Convoy came
from ordinary donors in Canada
but every time Trudeau has a problem in
Canada he looks to look to the right
wing of the United States as his
convenient villain but what do you think
he's going to going to do now when he
when the people in the United States and
in the government democrats should be
pissed with this as well
he's saying that the the United States
Supreme Court is an agency of horrific
decisions and implying that they're
deliberately bringing great pain to
American women and stirring up anger and
I'll tap that off by by pointing out one
other thing you've already had a knight
of Rage you've had people storming the
private houses of the U.S Supreme Court
you've had a a a a a a a a a a an
institution burnt down you've had the
legislature I think it was in Arizona
invaded so that the police said well you
know if it were a reverse situation
words of encouragement from an outside
prime minister saying that the decision
was horrific and that it's going to
cause anger on an issue this hot
that was grotesquely irresponsible
and if we're going to blame people's
actions on public Words which is a
liberal thing to do
then part of the Mayhem that was we're
going to see in the United States over
this decision comes from encouragement
from our dilettante prime minister here
in Canada well I also don't understand
it strategically in some real sense
because it looks self-evident that the
Democrats are going to face a
catastrophic electoral defeat in the
fall and that means that the Trudeau
government assuming it lasts the next
two or three years that it's
hypothetically likely to last is going
to be dealing with a much more
conservative Ally on the southern front
and the steps taken to alienate all
those people especially after he also
blamed the Maga type Republicans for
funding the trucker Convoy to
destabilize Canadian democracy just
doesn't seem like the most diplomatic or
wise thing to do when you're dealing
with people who are well crucial to us
on the trading front let's say and not
say nothing of defense well one thing
you don't look for in the pronouncements
of Mr Trudeau is wisdom that's a
ridiculous effort to begin with and it
will give you no results whatsoever what
you should look for and which is given
evidence of over the last seven years
that what he might lack in intellectual
sweep Immortal compensates by a certain
Instinct of cunning and the reason for
slamming role versus Wade is that he
thinks he's found yet another issue even
though it's in another country and even
though the judicial determinations of
the U.S Supreme Court have no valence or
relevance to Canadians nonetheless it's
the kind of as yeah he calls it's kind
of raw meat to use an expression he
likes a lot when he applies it to the
concern kind of raw meat you throw out I
found it even more annoying
that here you are in Rwanda
on your way to a castle in Bavaria being
being hit by this RCMP Scandal and you
got to jump out of your chair three
minutes after the Supreme Court decision
is announced to let the world know you
think their deliberation was horrific to
stir up the already angry hard leftists
in the United States and detract from
any attention being paid to issues in
Canada like inflation gasoline prices
food prices the closing of parliament
but I won't go on with those until we
get to them
let's start with the issue of the
strange political times that we seem to
be in in Canada and perhaps touch on the
collusion of the NDP and the media in
producing that because my sense is as I
mentioned before that in over the span
of My Life One of the great advantages
of a parliamentary system is that when a
government
especially one that doesn't have a
strong majority becomes continually
Scandal ridden that the
the precedent is for Parliament to
dissolve and for an election to take
place now I know we just had an election
that was completely unnecessary but we
have a situation in Canada where the
Liberals have moved radically to the
left they've supplanted the NDP who are
supporting them constantly in what is
essentially a coalition government and
we have the horrible fascistic spectacle
of the Canadian government radically
subsidizing the Legacy Media in Canada
in general and the CBC ins specifically
to the tune of 1.2 billion dollars a
year to produce no audience and a set of
facts that are entirely convenient to
the Trudeau government and so we have
this perfect storm especially if you add
to that the fact that Trudeau has
essentially gutted Parliament for two
years partly partly as a consequence in
principle of the covet Scandal but they
just announced this week or last week
that virtual Parliament is going to
continue for another year which year
this is just every month every week
there's something else the Trudeau
government does that I find so
Preposterous and unbelievable that it
makes me think that there's something
wrong with the way that I'm looking at
the news what the hell's going on with
the virtual Parliament what is this
well I'll take the virtual problem at
first but I am going to circle back to
another thing that you are not several
of the things you've already mentioned
I thought for what is worth and insofar
as I can think I thought that even when
the pandemic was fresh and we didn't
have a clear understanding of its true
risks or its true range or whether the
vaccines or or or other emoluments were
going to be available I thought that
even then
when at least the grocery store clerks
were still on the job and at that time
by the way so were the much praised
truckers Mr Trudeau himself came out to
say we must thank them for bringing our
food and our medicines in the beginning
of this pandemic I thought even then
that the idea that the people who had
been elected
to the highest office that this Federal
this country can offer the House of
Commons in a time of emergency that's
when they do meet
and even if there was some element of
risk involved that's when they do meet
now that was at the beginning
now you dropped down two years and the
vacillating regime of covert it went up
it went down they changed this they
changed that wear a mask don't wear a
mask these are good these are good take
one vaccine take two vaccines take two
more booster shots stay six feet apart
don't pick yep after two whole years
when they finally concede that their own
mismanagement can't continue forever
the idea that as he closes down
Parliament on June the 22nd of 2022
in not Coalition in collusion that Mr
Singh he announces in advance
that there's already got it eviscerated
disemboweled parliament of the last two
years is now going to have another full
year with people sitting in their in
their washrooms in some cases going on
Zoom there's a side point to this it's
important to make it
just because you have the MPS talking to
each other by some teleconference that's
not Parliament
the reason that Parliament stands and
the reasons that Parliament always were
they are places of assembly the
Newfoundland house for example actually
wears the etymological force it is the
House of Assembly and why do you talk of
assembly Canada is vast its geography is
almost its defeat and therefore because
of its vastness the various regions
personalities and cultures of those
regions are vastly dissonant different
to use the Trudeau term diverse it's
important for MPS from all over the
country to be in one place for a
continuous time to have interaction
response and mutual communication even
if it's argument they have to learn from
each other the whole of the country
you don't do that with a zoom on your
bookcase well one of the things I've
been thinking about on the Putin front
is that one of the consequences of of
the covid lockdowns is that is that
world leaders haven't had a chance to
meet face to face and now we substituted
Zoom for that and zoom is a narrow
channel now I've been in Washington too
and increasingly the uh Congressman in
Washington don't move to Washington and
40 percent of them sleep in their
offices they don't have apartment
buildings and so they haven't built the
social communities in Washington that
would enable the Democrats to talk to
one another or the Democrats to talk to
the Republicans across the aisle in the
social interactions that you have if you
generate a shared community and so this
rush to substitute narrow channels of
electronic communication merely out of
convenience we have absolutely no idea
whatsoever that what that will do to the
Parliament and it could would easily
destroy it well I'll tell you what
it already does it to Parliament Zoom
Parliament is a ghost it is the ghost of
a dead Parliament the notion of again
that the 300 plus MPS being forced by
the nature of the country to be in
Ottawa to be in one huge building to
share the same chamber to meet each
other informally that's how they
informed themselves of the range and
nature of the country number two as you
just point out the IDE once you get
there you you get this interaction the
the fraud politics of the United States
are partially because these people don't
simply meet
it's very easy to form enemies on
Twitter and Facebook and Via Zoom but if
you sit down and have a meal even with a
person who wildly disagrees with you and
you have to exchange the normal human
courtesies you've suddenly modify this
visceral response that you throw out so
rudely on on this ghost network of
Twitter and Facebook well what you what
you seem to see
on the electronic communication front is
that differences get highlighted and
similarities vanish and it is definitely
the case that if you sit down with
someone for a meal or if your kids are
on the same baseball team that you find
out that you're really about 90 percent
the same and 10 different and when the
channels of communication are narrowed
that inverts and flips and and then we
also could add to that Rex the fact that
well parliament's a check on executive
power and we could use some checks on
Trudeau's power but when you and I were
much younger
and maybe only about 20 years ago the
Press was also an independent check and
now the Press is in the pockets of the
government and I called that fascist
earlier and I I meant that what we're
seeing worldwide is a fascist Enterprise
weirdly enough on the left side
um that involves a collusion between
media technology and government and
fascism the root of the word fascism
means to bind together because Central
right exactly the central element of a
fascist state is collusion of the of the
elites let's say and the eradication of
any checks and balances and that sort of
that's reminiscent to me of the
desirability of that is reminiscent to
me of Trudeau's Express admiration for
the Chinese Communist party and its
efficiency in moving forward let's say
on the environmental front something
that he's
expressed uh explicit admiration for and
so and I would also say that's hurting
Canada's International reputation in
ways that Canadians just don't seem to
realize
including among moderate liberal types
well let's go first with the with the
media and the fact that the media the
main media in this country Legacy Kalama
you will
have accepted the devil's handshake
it simply cannot be otherwise said
that the press the media the instruments
of inquiry skepticism and test
can be directly subsidized by the one
major institution the whole government
which in many ways they are charged by
their very nature to investigate to be
skeptical about to inquire to collide
with to contest
and the idea that in this soft
environment you accept huge sums of
money and by the way the traffic between
the news media and the political media
how many journalists end up as aids to
the ministers well Mr Trudeau's Chief
aide Ben chin began on the Toronto Media
Station the the cross-currence between
journalism and politics that's one thing
now by the way in addition to the money
that's a that's a really big thing and
it should be a shock to any journalist
here's another thing that gives you an
even deeper and I think in certain ways
a more worrisome collusion and that is
that the mindset of the majority and I'm
not one of these conspiracy people about
the Press but I know it enough from 25
or 26 years in it that the mindset the
mentality
the the tendency the major media offices
of parliamental energy are already in
tune with the agenda of the government
they are constantly either indirectly
subtly or not so subtly actually
supporting the government and making
themselves the opposition to the
opposition it is really quite remarkable
with the RCMP scandals with emergency
act with truckers with inflation with
oil
that Pierre poly there who was still an
Outsiders looking in gets a lot of hits
he's going to tear a property apart
whereas this good giant media it's
because they share the agenda they share
the social identities business they
certainly shared the diversity thing and
the obsession with racialists at
politics and of course the uh the the
absorption entirely on the idea of
sexual agenda the improta in other words
all of the social justice issues the
press and the Parliament are in the same
place
so yeah being paid for his Fascism and
and finally I truly with the China I
think that's very good when he was not
yet leader and when he felt he could
relax so easily and talk about these
things that's what we call the Kinsey
gaffe you say the thing you really mean
and in his case you know if we were
China I could turn the environment
around on the dime that the real thing
there is not so much the dictatorship of
China it shows that he has a fondness
for the ability to merely operate by
Fiat and if you study the last five and
six years and in particular the period
from covered on covert was a continuous
Fiat that completely gutted the Civil
Rights the Charter of Rights he has
people fired he has people and then when
the Convoy comes it calls them racist
homophobes misogynists a fringe minority
that should not note this word that
should not be tolerated his empathy for
China basically constitutes one element
of the personality he does not does not
like opposition he guts Parliament to
make sure that there isn't any and he
makes a deal he makes the deal with his
co-signer Mr Singh so that there will
never be a confidence motion and if he
wants to have Parliament Zoom for
another year Mr cigna's there with the
ready salute and the genuine Affliction
to give it to him
yeah well the the uh the this this
certainty of compulsion let's say that
drives Trudeau forward seems to be
rooted in his
false moral sense that because he's
concerned like the other members of the
Davos World economic Forum Etc with the
long-term health of the planet whatever
that means that nothing that gets in his
way could possibly be regarded as
ethical or moral and so and the Press
who's now more than ever made up of
political globalist utopian wannabes do
everything they possibly can to collude
and to move that agenda forward and then
we could add to that Rex I went through
this new bill c-11 because I'm one of
the people whom whom it will
hypothetically affect although I have a
number of Maneuvers up my sleeve so to
speak to bypass that entirely and I know
Canadians don't understand this but
let's say that the New Media
which is the internet itself was capable
of producing some of the opposition to
the globalists and Trudeau that the
Legacy Media have abandoned it I'm
thinking of people like say uh Russell
Brand who's on the left and not just
mentioned you know any of the
conservative commentators in the United
States but um
now what the now what the Canadian what
the what the bill c-11 has done is
basically and this is unbelievable I
can't believe I read it correctly they
basically defined all internet content
of any sort
as subject to the same crtc Canadian
radio and television uh what is it
Corporation I don't remember the last
word that doesn't really matter no it
doesn't matter they've defined them as
broadcasters that are equivalent let's
say to CBC or CTV now the reason that
those broadcasters are different was
because the government had to parse up
the airwaves because the airwaves were
actually a scarce resource now and the
internet is not a scarce resource and
now as far as I can tell reading the
reading Bill C11 which is an
unbelievably vague document if a
internet service provider a private one
so a small business person like me let's
say doesn't broadcast in French and
English and in indigenous languages and
to any diverse range of people with
disabilities
and highlight Canadian content then the
government can do what it needs to do to
de-prioritize their distribution and
they'll do that by putting pressure on
the search engine providers like YouTube
and Google or just stopping them all
together and I read this bill and all of
it again Rex too the bill is couched in
all this diversity inclusivity and
Equity terminology which it's the same
solution to every problem right and so
not only do we have this massive press
collusion with the government that's
absolutely unconscionable in a western
democracy and and but we also have now
the government clamping down more
viciously than in any other developed
country on the freedom for Canadians to
get access to all of the all of the
information on the internet not just
that produced by Canadians
I'm inclined to believe that this idea
that these ah intellectuals it's mainly
a shallow cabinet I don't care how
condescending that sounds what it mainly
is
that they somehow or other have been
given vatican-like infallibility to
judge what is correct and is not correct
to make decisions that will hold back by
the way the whole idea of disinformation
and misinformation coming out of the
mouths
of this government
I mean
they are the greatest purveyor of
confusion and evasion in the law the
idea that they then are going to be the
kind of grandmas or Mrs Grundy as it
used to be called in the 19th century
and protected tender sensibilities of
Minds that are better than their own
yeah I'm tired of people and I'm sure
you are too because it's getting so
cliched to bringing up George Orwell but
because he put the stamp on it and gave
the template the idea that a central
Authority runs thought and speech and
makes judgments on what is and was not
and under the banner of diversity
inclusion and equity which is really a
hidden a hidden ideology
pumped up my vast self-righteousness and
granting pseudo-infallability to those
who are sensitive we know this is not
the case Mr Trudeau got rid of his only
Aboriginal female Minister there's
Equity there's diversity
they confused this is a big Point too
they confuse either at DeVos which you
referenced or any other high meeting
with saying that you are virtues is the
same thing as being it and there's a
hidden not a hidden there's a blatant
arrogance attached to any government
that thinks that in the modern
communication system that it should have
any business outside of the exact things
that are defined by law as incitement
and real rabid hate
they will call hate something they
simply don't like it's not an easy it's
not an easy emotion to Define C11 as
Michael geiston I know you follow him
Michael Geist is the professor of
communication who most and most
articulately and most deeply is warning
over and over to give this bunch
that can't issue a passport
that have a pay system for their own
civil servants that's three or four
years
misfunctioning that can't let passengers
walk out of Pierce in the airport within
less than 24 hours should suddenly have
the government
of the thoughts and reactions and
speeches and positions and films and
talks like this like yours
it's absurd but it's more than that
this is truly the right thing
I mean what is this gulping for more
power than you need well it's the
imposition of an ideology and go back to
your China Point here's the reason that
he may really admire China
because China it happens to be communism
in that case China is fired only as was
Russia by an ideology by a set of narrow
ideas from which no deviation no
criticism under penalty of Exile or
death is allowed not as hard over here
but die is an ideology an ideology makes
those claims and fills those who hold it
with a completely and completely
unacceptable level of moral certitude
not certainty bill c-11 is a disaster
and one more quick point it is shameful
it is shameful to the essence that the
main main Canadian press are not as one
voice
and a one intense voice saying we're not
having this
we are simply not having this you are
not going to rule on what is information
and not information you are not going to
rule on the presence of citizens on the
new channels of communication and seeing
you've already fouled the official or
Legacy means to some serious degree
we're certainly not going to allow you
to put a pillow over the mouth of the
only possible new exchanges that we have
it's a terrible idea and idea apart from
arrogance righteousness and the belief
in his own infallibility I can't see
wise but
why aren't the MPS even in his own party
saying Justin you're dreaming you're out
of touch we don't want to go there we're
not following you on this where's the
courage in any of these caucuses they
hand wave about diversity inclusivity
Equity the environment and then in Bill
C11 they add the protection of the
Canadian culture to that and which
sounds like something taken out of like
1979 or 1980 it's such an outdated idea
and one of the other Terror terrifying
things about Bill c-11 is that we won't
in Canada if this is actually enforced
with the collusion let's say of Google
and YouTube and so forth and the forced
collusion in some sense because those
companies are not going to break the law
Canadians won't even know what
information is being hidden from them
because the laws will take the form of
invisible algorithms that merely
de-prioritize at the listing of content
that doesn't meet the impossible
criteria that have been laid down and
Bill c-11 is basically written in a way
that allows the government to interfere
with the promulgation of any information
that they deem unacceptable for any
reason because there are so many
restrictions on what you're allowed to
do now that there's no possible way that
that any
any member of the alternative media can
meet the criteria it's just not possible
and it won't just be YouTube
broadcasters and podcasters it's going
to be people who provide all sorts of
services online because the bill is
written in such a vast manner that the
provision of any services on the
internet and we're talking about the
internet here right which is something
people really depend on that that'll all
fall under the invisible auspices of a
tiny cotery of ideologically adult
bureaucrats and algorithms there are so
many points to make in this as long as
this is 2022 I haven't got the year
exactly right but 16 37 1640 or
somewhere near that
it was when Milton Road area forgettica
which is when parliament of Great
Britain was deciding then that you know
squirrels pamphlets usually of of a
religious orientation uh had to be had
to be prohibited had to be censored and
of all the the great speeches about free
expression uh the value of books uh the
value of publication of all the defenses
of real free speech and real free
thought the Ariel paganiga is classic
and as Milton says you know whoever knew
truth to be defeated in an open contest
now that's 1637.
this is 2022.
and how it can come to pass
that a government with a military power
with the ability to imprison we were
making fun of or scared by the big tech
companies Google slanting his search
machine Twitter deciding who should be
banned and who should not be banned who
should be suspended and who should not
be suspended we didn't like it when the
private Enterprise operators did they
make deals with China how does the
Google and Facebook and and Twitter work
in those Enviro we said my Lord a couple
of guys from you know from from the tech
Valley ruling which thoughts can get on
platforms and which cannot we thought
that was pretty all right it still is
pretty bad
but now you have as Michael Geist said
this is an alarming thing because Geist
is a very calm individual he's a solid
intellectual and on this subject in
particular he knows what he's saying we
have the only legislation
in this in this Arena
that parallels get ready for it North
Korea
you part all this out and by the way
there's another reason why that's a new
first for Canada yeah but must tie this
together why do you think he thought it
was very useful to have a zoom
Parliament for another year
because the Gathering Together of all
the people who might wake up to this and
who might because of personal
interactions across the lines might see
that this is not a step too far
this is a gigantic leap between mountain
peaks too far no he wants to Parliament
close down or as I said emasculated
so that he can bring in in his life this
is his last term I'll make that a
declarative statement whatever big moves
he wishes to make but again in this
particular case
we've had it as I said we go back to
further Milton even you don't let power
determine information thought and speech
I mean if if Donald Trump were president
and decided to regulate the internet
nine tens of the world would fly up
Justin can go on about how horrific the
justice system of the Supreme Court is
while up here he plays a game halfway
between Animal Farm in 1984.
uh by the way he's making as you pointed
out there are so many scandals that one
gulps and swallows the other
they he has a scandal management that's
better than any other
have a fresh Scandal and then we'll kill
the previous one it's hard to follow him
yeah well exactly well you you asked a
little earlier
what Scandal we should perhaps focus on
most intently and it is very difficult
to to do that when they're coming at you
at a mile a minute when you have like 15
things that have been done in the last
six months that should have caused the
collapse of the government but I would
say the worst thing that Trudeau did
it's a hybrid between invoking and then
rescinding the emergencies act for no
reason whatsoever then he relied on the
information provided to him deceitfully
by CBC who retracted it and then worst
of all
freezing the bank accounts and
interfering with the Bitcoin exchanges
because Trudeau established a precedent
now that should
terrify Canadians of any political
engagement whatsoever which is that if
you happen to be peripherally involved
with a demonstration no matter how legal
the demonstration is at the moment and
you donate money that first of all
you'll be tracked and that's bad enough
like that's terrifying enough but not
only tracked but that all your ability
to interact with the entire economic
system because it's not just freezing
your bank accounts right it's freezing
your mortgage it's freezing your Visa
it's making it impossible for you to
withdraw any cash it's putting your
family at risk it's to compare this to
what the Chinese are doing with the
social credit system is no leap and
that's a terrible conspiratorial thing
to say but it also reflects a deep
underlying reality and I'm telling you I
I I can't tell you how many people have
expressed shock and dismay to me
throughout the United States and through
Europe about the fact that Trudeau well
implemented the emergencies act and and
and and and suspended civil liberties
and then froze the bank accounts
especially because Canada has had a
great reputation on the financial front
for 150 years the Integrity of our
financial System including our banks has
been one thing that Canada really got
right and now what would you think if
you were if you were a foreign investor
or or anyone seriously considering doing
business with Canada when you know now
that if you're a Republican
ah and heaven forbid a trump supporter
but a republican even that your views
are now deemed so extreme that it's neat
and just to declare them an emergency
and to steal all your money with no
trial with no due process of law
completely arbitrarily and behind the
scenes
no Scotiabank apologized about two weeks
ago I don't know if any of the other big
Banks they said they did it under duress
well that's because they're bloody
cowards and they're foolish as well
because they've they've taken a
catastrophic hit to their International
reputation
well I'll go let's start at the again go
back to where you began yourself
the imposition of revocation before
ratification of the emergency act that
had about seven to eight days of life
we have not had yet we didn't have it
then that's for sure
we have not had yet the list
of of circumstances that justified
that's a really big word just gave
Justice to the action
that justified the imposition of the
equivalent of the war measure of that
because that's what it was
to completely suspend the Charter of
Rights on a philosophic basis alone he
basically nullified the entire civil
liberties of the entire population of
this entire country because some trucks
were parked on an Ottawa Street that's
only the first part
you mentioned the CBC reports that have
been dismissed
and that he relied on them I'm not sure
that's entirely the case
he may have had some of his own Spin
Masters passed the stories on the CBC in
the first place I have no idea if that
was true or not but we had other
instances where you had an arson attempt
in in a building in Ottawa which was
dramatically enhanced by news coverage
and Mendocino or whatever his name is
use that they're going to burn down
buildings and lock the doors of people
can't get out we need an emergency Act
you had all sorts of fabricated faults
or totally misleading assertions during
a pseudo crisis and then you had the
Capstone
that these people who drove 2500 miles
in February across the northern
landscape to protest a given government
issue actually were there and had to be
paid attention to because they wanted to
overthrow the Canadian government
that statement is so extreme that is
beyond laughable and so when he calls it
back before the Senate gets a chance to
ratify it
the legislation says You must have an
inquiry when you call out the highest
the most lethal the thermonuclear
legislation of any government he can't
avoid having a committee set up
and I think it was last week or 10 days
ago that Christia Freeland who was the
deputy Deputy Prime Minister because
Jack beat Singh is the official Deputy
he's finally before a parliamentary
committee and when they asked her
questions either about the RCMP or about
this or about the the scorn and
righteousness and smugness of response
the idea that the the greatest invasion
of civil liberties it has been passed by
with some mellow a response and that
gives you that gives them the appetite
then if I could call up the emergency
act and call a group of of Savvy Common
Sense citizens Fringe minority racist if
I could if I can set one part of the
community against the other
and that division there's where the
appetite comes from Bill C11 got away
with the emergency act well obviously I
can bring in legislation that is even
more toxic oh yes I can interfere with
RCMP investigations because it seems
when I went to the agricon and violated
all the ethics provision the RCMP then
said well that might be criminal but
we're not considering criminal charges
jagmeet Singh is at the center of a lot
of this and that's the point that
eventually we will get to I'm sure but
the emergency Act is I think because
it's not justified because it was for
political convenience because he
extemporized a narrative that these were
villains and Americans and were being
funded by dark right-wing forces from
outside the country
that's the worst because it confounds so
many issues together it's also a
stunning accusation yeah it is levied
against 50 percent of the population of
our greatest Ally to the South people in
principle that he has to work with us
certainly is going to have to work with
when the fall comes and so that's just
well that's just another example of His
stunning lack of wisdom uh and his
carelessness with his with his actions
so so let's let's talk a little bit
about a bit more about the interference
with the RCMP I'd like you to make some
comments about that if you would
well that's that again people who know
Canadian politics and I want to
apologize but I'll simply say I regret
uh that it's not so fascinating that the
people who listen the range of viewers
that you have uh would may not be as
intimate with it as we would we should I
don't know about wishing on them but
nonetheless well it's a good example of
fascist collusion though I would say and
well that's a threat to everyone in the
west yeah but it also has a great
precedent the biggest scandal in terms
of principle in terms of something
fundamental something that reaches to
the rule of the law came a couple of
years back when he had an attorney
general I mentioned her already
the indigenous lady from BC are getting
your name fooled up in my head for just
a second
she took a stand at snc leveling should
not get special provisions and she was
Rebel she was the attorney general and
yet people from his pmo office himself
uh the highest civil service
chapter ministers kept pressing kept
pressing her to change her mind she
warned the prime minister
if you are attempting to influence an
attorney general
who was a singular position in any
cabinet if you were attempting to this
is terrible so for eight or nine months
she resisted
she said no the rule of law can't be
politically interfered with now this was
this was a prime minister on his office
and AIDS and ministers
attempting to bend
the operation of Justice in Canada and
eventually Mr Raymond gets fired or
basically leaves herself and another
fine female Captain minister went with
her but after a bit of a flutter even
though he denied any influence he said
in the globe mail the story is false it
was proven to be true Jump Ahead two
years and now you find out that after
the worst bass casually of that kind in
Canada the murder of 22 people in Nova
Scotia
that the prime minister's office and his
political aides are pressuring or asking
or telling uh the head of the RCMP
Brenda lucky
to get information from the
investigators in Halifax because they
were bringing in gun control legislation
next week in other words they wanted to
absorb some of the emotional context and
the high sensitivity of a a singular
tragedy so they could Advance a
political agenda and didn't mind pushing
and she didn't mind agreeing
to put pressure on a Halifax
investigation
now you you hear back that the the uh
that Mr Lem all the relevant cabinet
ministers oh no Mr Trudeau had to really
find the thing we put no undue influence
on the RCMP the only one word in that
sentence you have to pay attention to
it's undue right exactly yeah and so Rex
this is all a pattern as far as I'm
concerned I'm speaking as a clinician
here although I hesitate to do so but
I've been watching Trudeau for a long
time I found it appalling I found what
he was doing appalling right from the
beginning because Trudeau was enticed
into running for leadership as a
consequence of what I would describe as
a successful appeal to his overweening
narcissism he had none of the education
or ability or experience necessary to do
something as complex as lead a modern
country and it was obvious to all and it
should have been obvious to him that
this single reason that he was picked by
the utterly cynical liberals who chose
him was first of all his Pleasant uh
personal appearance and perhaps not
first and foremost but first and
foremost his name Trudeau the dynastic
name the fact that he already had
broad scale marketing and sales appeal
and that was enough
for him to justify to himself becoming
prime minister and then you know maybe
you don't want to damn someone for that
because just because he was pure
Trudeau's son doesn't mean he doesn't
have ability and so it would be possible
that someone like that could
take the humble approach and decide that
well better him than some evil
conservative let's say and that he could
carefully learn to be competent and to
do a good job but instead he leapt Into
The Fray immediately appointing 50
percent of his cabinet as women even
though they were only 25 percent of the
MPS and thereby perhaps fatally
impairing the qualifications and
competence of the cabinet and then
doubling down on his idiot ideology
d-i-e let's say diversity inclusivity
and Equity plus a bit of
environmentalism on the side and a
hatred for the energy industry and he's
been fiddling that fiddle ever since and
this theme of narcissism which I think
is apt
permeates everything that he he does the
admiration for China the dismissiveness
that he manifests when he's ever asked
questions the overweening legislation
like Bill c-11 that he passes without a
second's consideration for the fact that
maybe we could use some checks and
balances in the governmental system on
the off chance we might not be a hundred
percent right about all our ideological
presuppositions
the fact that he basically ignores
Parliament and now that he's made it
virtual and then we could add to that is
another one Rex which I think is very
interesting the fact that he denied
unvaccinated Canadians about six million
of them yes the the right to travel
which is a big deal in a country like
Canada and a big deal in other countries
as well but not only did he do that but
then when every country in the world
virtually had released people from the
covid mandates and relaxed the
impositions they put on the rights he
did not release Canadians from that
travel ban until months after there was
every bit of evidence that it should
have been done and all I can say about
that was that that was that was sheer
bloody narcissistic malevolence there
was Zero excuse for that and the mere
fact that he didn't rescind that policy
months ago that in itself should have
been enough for the government to fall
and if jagmeet Singh had an ounce of
spine or sense and he has neither he
would not be supporting this government
in the manner that he does especially
given the putative NDP what would you
say affiliation for the Common working
man which is a complete bloody bunch of
rubbish that those days are long gone
all the union guys are out of the NDP we
have an elite set of utopians whose
presuppositions make the liberal idiocy
look like well look look almost like
nothing in contrast and the
self-righteousness and moralizing that
goes along with that and so what Rex why
do you think Canadians
have found themselves in this position
and why isn't there more broad scale
outrage if not rioting in the streets
about what's happening at the federal
government level
well there are two or three things that
I could say that are I think fairly
relevant in this context
the first thing is that when he first
came in by the way whether it's
narcissism or not that being as it is a
clinical as well as poetic term I don't
think there's much doubt of it if you're
using it in just a conventional lay
language uh why you would install as the
leader of the country well it came also
because the Liberals have been so
ill-advised when they picked up for
example Mr Dion or the traveling
political salesman Mr Ignatius who left
his enemy within hours of losing and
never even said goodbye sometimes the
appetite for novelty triumphs over any
Prudence or consideration of forethought
but having seen them for the first term
and having seen the Glorious appetite
for display
and for the the gesture uh whether it's
you know doing some yoga standing on a
bench or making sure that you show up in
in the right mood at a certain event or
attending the pride parade there's
there's no single symbolic gestural
action that he ever avoided and he
signaled he signaled time into it is a
it is in the early days especially it
was a government of signals that he was
also a semi-celebrity Vogue magazine did
a thing on him and the Canadian press
had a wonderful faith I I never
understood how supine they could be so
quickly they talked about when we were
having some dissatisfactions with the us
that he was on a charm offensive and
that a charm offensive would disarm
either Mr Trump or whomever it was that
he was dealing now you asked a deeper
question in the early days yes you could
put it up why are Canadians not more
resistant well like two or three reasons
they're quite solid
especially as these things have
accelerated and intensified meaning the
invasions of government into areas where
it should not be long there was this two
years of the regime that more than any
other provincial and federal governments
imposed you had economy the economy
knocked it to bits we do not have an
inventory of the tens of thousands
perhaps hundreds of thousands of
independent and small businesses that
gasp for air
that waited for the next in-breath
merely to see if they could make another
day in the last two years you had
relatives unable to see their Elder
parents or or Elder relatives you know
you had social economic
psychological and medical obsessions and
anxieties that went from the from the
primary from the intimate exchange of
mother father daughter son to the broad
scale and during that particular period
I think everyone was some somewhat off
balance and once again the news media
were not doing their job they were all
online we well we must close everything
down and you could have an announcement
in the beginning of the pandemic as I've
already referenced that masks are bad
they actually that came from time and
two months later that you must wear them
and no one in the media wanted to
collide those two contradictions and say
well
are you really as expert as you say
that's the first reason Colvin took away
a lot of the energies that might have
been invested in the public sphere and
paying attention to politics because so
many other strains that are much more
intimate and close were at play secondly
and I think this is really really
telling
that in the in the present five and six
months when this thing really has gave
come to new levels
whatever was the deal
that the NDP which traditionally is
really the oppositional not the
conservatives the NDP are the ones that
really put the bite on the Liberals
remember the war measures Act was the
Forerunner of the emergency Act
what was the name of the man who even in
a dent genuine crisis you could make a
case that they apprehended Insurrection
of the war measures act could be just I
said make a case
and it was popular especially
in English Canada in that time who stood
up against it who took the Flack who
took the bad public relations it was
Tommy Douglas
the leader of the new Democratic party
saying it went too far Mr Trudeau the
Elder should not have that power
in a new world where you didn't have a
genuine crisis and when the war when the
emergency Act was invoked in my judgment
for Spite and Parkinson reasons Jack
made sin had already guaranteed Justin
Trudeau would have no parliamentary
interference I don't know what to do
they talk about dental plans and a few
things the NDP won but I don't know the
internalities what was the discussion
what went on between Mr Trudeau and Mr
Singh that he would oblige that meaning
Singh for the next three years and
preserve them from criticism this is the
time well it's quite stunning isn't it
that the NDP can enter into a pact with
the devil let's say and none of us even
know why what's in it for you jag meat
oh nothing well well nothing doesn't
seem like a very good bargain so what
the hell is going on behind the scenes
where are the I this is these this is a
really good question
the NDP does have some fairly vigorous
uh and and occasionally aggressive MPS
they certainly can take on the Tories
when they want and they're by the way
they love taking on the Tories
that's a big [__] is more relatively
speaking
where are they in the because the NDP
does have that that moral kind of Aura
and people who join the NDP like to
believe at least that there is a
morality driving then that is of a
different scale or of a pure value than
the other parties why are they letting
Mr Sing
so desecrate the central image of the
entire why aren't some of the MPS in the
party talking about and I also ask when
it comes to the RCMP thing or the
emergency act why aren't liberals
liberal MPS even some ministers
Wilson rabo did it why is it that we're
not hearing from Individual empty
they've been elected by a constituency
they do have autonomy if they want to
use it they said talk about caucus
discipline there's only discipline in
the caucus if you accept it and if you
think the prime minister or a captain
Minister has stepped over the line or
the leader of your party is traducing
the reputation of your party then an MP
in the NDP or an MPS in the liberal
caucus will say hey Mr Trudeau is going
too far with the information legislation
he went far too far with the emergency
act and his attempt to put the vision
especially against the working class of
Canadians during the trucker protest
that was most unseemly we don't have
opposition from the media in the main
and obviously with Mr Singh guaranteeing
Mr Trudeau that's how Mr Trudeau could
cancel Parliament for next year this is
the central Dynamic of our entire of the
entire political moment of our time and
I have not seen one major interview from
one major one major interview from one
major presence on the Canadian media
scene sit jagmeet Singh down 30 minutes
and let's have the story you have not
seen it yeah well that's unbelievable
and well maybe it's partly the
fragmentation of Parliament and so all
the MPS feel isolated and then I know
from talking to conservative MPS who
didn't exactly distinguish themselves in
terms of their courage over the last
four years either that as individuals
they're all terrified they're being
isolated and mobbed and the fact that
Parliament is fragmented and that the
media and the New Media for that matter
is more than capable and willing to mob
we could use the former Attorney General
as case in point means that people on
the on the MP side the back benchers are
cowed in a way that I think is
unparalleled so let's turn rex because
it's very difficult to cover all the
scandals and we haven't even touched on
another one that's major beyond belief
which is that Trudeau has run up more
debt in his short time in office than
every single prime minister in Canada
managed in total since the founding of
the state and the consequence of that
has been an incredible inflation asset
inflation especially in the housing
market and an unparalleled level of
inflation and you can add to that the
consequences of his idiot energy
policies which have emboldened Putin and
which have also produced an unparalleled
increase in Energy prices across Canada
and so we were also and then that's not
enough that's not enough no so no in the
past year I have tried to buy for what
it's worth a new car uh a couple of
small boats uh just fun boats and I know
that's a luxury item but that's not the
point
um a snowmobile I tried to make a vinyl
record and I've tried to get penguin
Random House to put out a double edition
of my book penguin couldn't do it
because there's a cardboard and paper
shortage
um the vinyl record industry has an 8 to
12 month delay you can't get a
snowmobile you can't get a small boat
and no one can buy a car and the reason
for that is the supply chains are so
disrupted that we that it's cataclysmic
one in five container ships are trapped
in ports at the moment because the ports
can't keep up with the demand we have no
idea how badly fragmented the supply
chains are and that's going to produce a
catastrophic uh outcome especially come
fall because we're going to have a very
difficult time moving enough food around
the world to say nothing of enough goods
and so we have a massive debt we have an
inflation that's starting to get out of
control yeah we have a housing bubble
that's no joke and we have and we have
supply chain disruptions the magnitude
of which have never been seen before at
least not in the last 30 years and that
pose a threat to the Integrity of the
entire world economic system and so
that's also seems to be a bit of a
problem that Trudeau has had a major
hand in uh producing and that's that's
and that's that's along with his stated
disinterest in financial matters because
he said that explicitly has no real
interest in economic matters
you'd never guessed that in 2015 he said
I could almost quote I'm looking you
straight in the eye now and I'm I'm
speaking to you honestly as I always do
this is when he was going to have 10
billion dollar deficits per year that by
we will return to a balance by by 2019.
now again pretty covet we can understand
spending of a considerable magnitude
Beyond any promise during the regime of
covet but the the extent to which this
government
wildly and we never did seek because
again he was operating from the cottage
he was walking down the steps of the
Rideau Hall Cottage rather than going to
Parliament all alone in a little Covey
of of of of of media people under a
canvas tent and he was throwing out
billions this way and billions that way
if you do not think
that the billions upon billions upon
billions that were
flushed out without scrutiny the auditor
general did not have adequate means to
survey them and they said that and they
asked for other people we're going to
have a harvest of scandals in years to
come but that's not the main point at
the point that you're making
that the spending levels of debt and
deficit were well over a trillion
dollars and the banks of the Bank of
Canada has already jacked up the
interest rate twice I talked to a
financial man just yesterday it's going
to be worse and worse and worse we have
had a holiday from economic reason
during this period and he has overspent
Stephen Harper was correct the spending
during covet may have been necessary but
this was Overkill I would say Overkill
with Magnum and it was not governed
they're even now trying to get back Serb
payments from one million Canadians
when the interest rates rise and people
who have houses and mortgages start to
learn what it is like to be in
previously normal times inflation hits
at the worst possible moment two full
years of economic Devastation because of
covert because of the regime they closed
down things that didn't have to be
closed they killed businesses we're
going to see tremendous Devastation
across and then the the de Jihad against
Alberta oil
that is the most that is criminally
Cupid
we are depriving not only Alberta but
the Canadian treasure during the now the
return prices of natural oil and gas
highest almost ever and we have made
them we're sorry Mr Trudeau Mr Singh
Elizabeth May and the capital of
professional environmentalists have made
poor Alberto out of Saskatchewan's oil
and gas industry a demonic presence
how do you reach the level
of
political insanity
that you kill a primary resource of your
own country
you this you were strange and anger
justifiably angered they are justifiably
angry a whole Province or or two
and at the same time when Mr Putin who
scorns the green philosophy and on that
one he's actually right uses the the
general flexion to greenism of Europe
and Canada to amass the power to use his
gas his oil as a leverage to control
Germany and to influence the operations
of Europe he couldn't be in Ukraine
today
if the green fantasy right and now to
threaten the UK with nuclear destruction
that was and then let's also point out
shall we that one of the consequences of
the uh sanctions so so heroically placed
on Putin by the idiot West is that the
ruble is at its highest level ever and
because oil prices have shot through the
roof Russia's actually arguably in some
ways in better economic shape after the
sanctions than they were before yeah so
that's just bloody brilliant as well and
this issue about uh what's happened on
the Russian front is anybody with any
sense looking at this up to say 10 years
ago knew perfectly well that by
dampening down oil and gas exploration
in in North America and in Europe that
we were playing into the hands of the
worst impulses of the Russians if you
had to have your head buried in the sand
or somewhere else to not notice that
absolutely explicitly and to hand wave
about idiot environmentalism while at
the same time producing this potentially
fatal dependent and so on Russian large
s and and Good Will is is an abdication
of political responsibility that you'd
have to look uh at history a long time
to find an example that would supersede
I wish and I I wish with utter futility
then again the Guardians of of our
public discourse uh the official and
Powerful press would would now forsake
they're deep and intimate marriage with
the green movement that they've had for
20 25 years if you watch TVO Ontario
you've seen An Inconvenient Truth which
was Al Gore's flush on the topic about a
hundred times CBC is officially if it
hasn't said so out loud is officially a
Greenpeace activist Network I would like
to see now then say okay this Embrace of
this virtue signaling Hollow ideology
has empowered the most dangerous
dictator on the earth the one with
nuclear weapons it has impoverished part
of the reason for the inflation in our
food at the present moment is because of
the energy crisis brought on by the by
the fatuous pursuit of energy sources
that can't work don't work aren't yet
developed and don't have the structure
or infrastructure even if they were
if you want to hear the rest of my
conversation with Rex Murphy please go
to
dailywiredplus.com and become a member
today